[Music]
okay watch the external
yeld it's a thing and we had to do it
okay I had to externally yield and and
get a y on the projection point
but I want to at
contact I want to start the compression
the compression is right there okay and
then I keep increasing it as she's
driving I keep increasing it you see
that and then very small movements press
so you can feel it okay so very small
movements
watch right there you see you see that
so if you watch my
external I made her do that but you can
see my hands moveed there you see that
so if she's driving driving I'll release
Here we are won't move there it is right
there right there okay so I'm I'm doing
that as we
go here
external
project roll
that's external to
projection
in and you can see now I don't need
those external need to move my
arm don't need to move my eyes Okay so
that's
why in order to get the absorption I
have to release the tension and then
if I move my arms I'm probably not doing
the absorption so you keep tasking
yourself with less tension and less
movement okay all right who's next
if I deviate you see you still are doing
the same compression it's right here
okay you
compress deviate
compress don't don't follow the same
turn
compress
compress um and then be cognizant let me
sh see how I'm trying to get out Dre a
gra so you can feel it see I'm trying to
get out what I do it instead is you I
feel that you see and then inside I
changing
that even when I make your elbow go up I
don't go against the thumb so I grip
then I'm inside the grip see that so you
have to be careful when you're trying to
do something to him because that starts
the
contestation the desire is contestation
the desire can only manifest because
what is happening has been made
undesirable do you see that so
instead Bo this is what I work with this
is what I work with and my and your
thumbs and your pinky on on the slippage
and all that is is is indicative of
whether I'm accepting of it or not so
careful like you want that elbow up and
so you did a thumb lock yes so inside W
okay try some more iido right we all
like cry trying to get them off
balance um but this is a superficial
understanding of kazushi do you see um
and it's not in alignment with non-c
contestation or wo way right and so we
have to go deeper what does non-c
contestation really mean total
acceptance you see um what is Wu total
acceptance
how can I do total acceptance I have to
lose the self because the self is always
a dichotomous entity that concentrically
expands out dichotomy which is just
contestation see and so what we're use
here is the poles of the pinky and the
thumb you see to tell you don't push
your pull don't open or close just stay
right where you're in and seek the Tom
in the middle which is neither pinky nor
thumb okay and so I don't I don't fight
you to get that kind of stuff I use the
motion there's the elbow right
here okay so try it some
more inward outward
spiral is in
it could be
small but it's the
shape it's the
shape
small see can be small or it didn't look
like it but inside it's coiling do you
understand the two are coiling so I
don't have to go
outward inward but I have to coil
TR half the
coil okay right try
it keep l
g and and let the
mudra do the work TR the
[Music]
okay careful of these like if you're
fighting freaking do it but here we're
training okay all right
okay watch those straight lines all
right
yes make
spirals Act linearly
now gone
little more curve on the Y
hand okay so watch the
uh the Y hand here see that okay so we
want to go
linear there all right you see that and
sometimes sometimes we turn him but then
it's linear there you see that yes okay
in or if I go spiral now I'm in the
shoulder that's part of the
problem again I'm turning him I go
spiral I got in the shoulder I missed
the center
okay that's why this is where the
internals come in I don't to touch I
don't have to push the shoulder to make
the center go back okay so as you're
doing your spiral
here pay pay attention to that I feel
that okay so as I do the spiral I'm not
going to pass you here and go into that
shoulder I keep this connection you see
this that connection that connection
that pushed you there I keep that
connection on the
spiral see that it doesn't go in the
shoulder so I'm not going like that in
the
shoulder but I'm not going like this
either I spiral
boom that that that part of the curve
from the vector that I'm staying
connected on is
linear do you see so
you you can spin the triangle it's now a
circle right you can you can hit with
the round object that that's kind of
what we're doing here so careful that
you like I feel I got him do you see
that and then you start pushing
instead come around the tanden all right
all
right got that okay